but let's jump into this first story we
have this from humanevents.com Durham
report reveals FBI Democrats staged soft
coup of trump Administration by Lemmy
Emmett Libby Emmons and I would like to
stress I believe this is newsguard
certified human events that means it is
true facts information the Durham report
begun in May 2019 was intended to
investigate allegations that President
Trump had engaged in collusion collusion
with Russia to alter the 2016
presidential election but if what it
found instead was an effort to undermine
Trump's presidency the confidence of the
American people and his administration
and to fuel media and Democrat
resentment and hatred for the man they
would sooner have shut on Fifth Avenue
then seen take the White House that's
some pretty good writing Libby they say
quote
our investigators determined that the
crossfire hurricane investigators did
not and could not corroborate any of the
substantive allegations contained in the
steel reporting not not was still able
to nor was still able to produce
corroboration for any of the reported
allegations even after being offered one
million or more by the FBI for such
corroboration the report reads later it
goes further to say that the information
was known to be rumor and speculation
Democrats planted fake evidence and then
used it against Trump in order to
justify their assumptions about his
guilt the FBI used that for probable
cause to further an investigation
without any basis at all within days of
their receipt the report reads the
unvetted and unverified steel reports
were used to support probable cause in
the FBI's fisa applications targeting
page a U.S citizen who for a period of
time had been an adviser to Trump as
discussed later in the report this was
done at a time when the FBI knew that
the same information Steeler provided to
the FBI had also been fed to the media
and others in Washington DC DC I'd like
to give you a simplified version so you
can understand what's going on the FBI
says no criminal culpability for a lot
of these people I think they're saying
like you know Hillary Clinton nothing
was overtly Criminal
here's how I see it imagine one day a
guy is uh walking past a bank carrying a
burlap sack and he walks up to the bank
steps drops the bag and walks away did
he commit a crime of course not he just
threw a burlap sack on the stairs of a
bank another guy walking into the bank
to cash a paycheck sees the burlap sack
and says oh somebody must have uh
accidentally left it outside picks it up
carries it inside throws it on the
ground in front of the counter catches
chicken leaves another guy crumples up a
note walking past the bank and throws it
through an open window you get where I'm
going with this one by one each of these
individuals did a small thing no single
person walked into that bank demanded
money filled a bag full of cash and fled
but each of these individuals did one
thing that if you were to analyze in and
of itself was not criminal but all
together
after all this goes down the bank teller
did fill the burlap sack with money and
then somebody did carry it outside then
someone else put it in the back of a
truck then someone else drove that truck
away and when the FBI comes and
interviews all of these individuals
they'll say look I don't know any of
these guys this was just in the public
and I stumbled upon it and the money was
taken from the bank and driven to a
secret hideout what happened with with
the the uh Trump Russia collusion was
that Democrats who wanted Trump
destroyed members of the media who
wanted Trump destroyed all claimed they
used publicly available information
to destroy Donald Trump's presidency
from the FBI claiming it was in the
media so we had to look into it but the
story in the media came from speculation
from people in the FBI it was one big
circular scheme and I think the only
reason Durham saying it's not criminal
is because he's going easy on these
people criminal indictments are
interpretable and I think anybody
looking at what these people did could
say if Adam Schiff goes on TV and he did
and says he has more than some more than
circumstantial evidence proving this
then there should be some kind of
criminal referral and we should not sit
back and allow all of these people to
destroy a presidency because I'll tell
you where we're at right now if nothing
comes of this if the extent of the
dermaport is yes they all did something
bad but it wasn't Criminal then there's
no country anymore because what's to
stop any political party from doing the
exact same thing to make sure no other
person can have a presidential
Administration again yeah exactly so if
nobody here broke the law that is an
indictment of our laws as they currently
stand so just to go over some of the
points that were made in the Durham
report
significant Reliance on investigating
leads that were funded by Trump's
opposition occurred uh they did not and
could not corroborate any of the
substantive allegations made by the
steel report the investigation was not
properly opened information was not
properly vetted it was carried out in an
improper manner FBI officials according
to the Durham report had a
predisposition to have a bias against
President Trump they didn't do their
basic due diligence and the FBI warned
the Clinton campaign of potential
Russian interference during the 2016
election but did not warn the Trump
campaign so people can say well in the
Durham report there isn't any statement
explicitly saying that there was an
attempt at a deep State coup he's just
saying that basically everyone who
handled this investigation was behaving
improperly because of their bias against
a sitting president well that's just the
distinction without a difference I don't
care if they all met in a cigar room and
rubbed their hands together and laughed
about the fact that they were trying to
subvert the US's democracy and the fact
that we had a democratic election and
people chosen out Outsider the fact is
what they were doing is functionally
identical they were trying to use bad
evidence to attempt to remove somebody
from Office who hadn't committed a crime
I think to me the most startling aspect
of this whole story is that the Durham
report at this Russia hoax that really
was just the opening Salvo of the deep
State's attempt to really nullify the
Trump presidency so I think it's
interesting if you sort of analyze the
Trump term through this Paradigm what I
mean by that the first impeachment
attempt the second impeachment attempt
the fact that the people who were
running you know PPO the presidential
personnel office the equivalent of HR in
the white house where a bunch of bush
Romney types were very establishment
Republicans so while it's important to
focus on the Russia hoax angle of it I
think it also shows you the extent to
which they were willing to go to to
thwart the Trump presidency before he
even became president right while he was
still a candidate so you can only
imagine how much they ratcheted up those
efforts to go after Trump once he
actually assumed office and assumed all
the The Leverage the powers that comes
with being president so I think it's
just it's such an interesting kind of
Paradigm to view all of the ways that
the Deep State really did go after Trump
I mean I think continues yeah exactly
facing so many different types of
lawsuits and investigations it's hard to
count them all what's a seditious
conspiracy Sheamus do you know well I
would say just based on the words it's
people conspiring to oppose legitimately
elected authorities so if like I don't
know a group of people had a plan to say
like disrupt a presidential
Administration something like that I
mean over the period of three years
before his election is that seditious
I'll I'm just gonna I'm not gonna mince
words here
they convicted proud boys of seditious
conspiracy why because they were at a
protest Riot on January 6th that's it a
one day thing the left has done the same
thing except instead of laundering their
talking points through groups right like
the right does say the proud boys or the
Patriot run all these different
federally cited groups they just do and
I think sort of more high brow more High
classes through ngos this was three
years of the FBI and Democrats and the
media all working together to stop a
presidential Administration that is the
biggest conspiracy this country has ever
seen and the only thing the only is only
one thing that they're claiming make
that makes it not a conspiracy is it was
all an accident that's right every lie
from Schiff Every Lie from the media
every action taken by the FBI all coming
together to create a massive Russia
collusion collusion investigation with
Pulitzer prizes whoops all of the
reporters all of the Democrats and all
of the feds slipped on a banana peel at
the exact same time did a backflip
landed perfectly and won awards for it
and it was just one big accident and are
there were Awards gonna be withdrawn I
mean this is what bothers me the most I
know it's important to confirm to
Revelations that uh the Durham report
produces but nothing's gonna happen
right the proud boys are gonna have to
go back to court to argue that the text
messages where there are saying where
should we meet up on January 6 prove
that they didn't have a plan for that
day meanwhile no one involved in this is
going to face uh conspiracy charges and
I hate uh to turn this into grimcast but
it really is incredibly frustrating and
disheartening there is no punishment for
what happened there can be when Trump
gets reelected I expect him to to have
an AG
start issuing these indictments start
convening grand juries and grand juries
they say can can indeed a ham sandwich
Bring It On present the evidence and say
did these people conspire you know what
I'll tell you this Tit for Tat let's
play Tit for Tat if you're gonna accuse
Donald Trump of working for the Soviet
Union then we're gonna accuse you of
conspiracy because y'all did say these
things let's just go ahead and assume
you did it on purpose yeah well remember
Tim what they're going to try to argue
is that you're an insane conspiracy
theorist for thinking that basically
every relevant person within the Deep
State being tilted against Trump and
trying to unseed him on bad evidence
isn't an actual core is an actual coup
I'm sorry that's a bridge too far but
them believing that the president of the
United States literally colluded with
Russia to rig the election and he was an
asset of Putin the entire time it's just
reasonable thinking and without any
evidence they could say that on National
Television to the American people well
let's slow down a second Sheamus do you
think the Democrats did what we know
they did you know it's a tough one man I
I gotta be honest yes or no yeah
yes or no I'm going to speak with my
lawyer yeah of course conspiracy theory
ah I got you and by the way I just have
to say I said you know a lot of my early
career had to do with focusing on
Chinese Communist Party infiltration if
Donald Trump's cardinal sin was you know
collaborating with the Russian
government which we know never happened
I mean the people who are accusing him
of doing that that is like textbook
projection in the sense that all of
these I I actually used to do this this
can tell you what kind of social life I
have but if you used to look at the
headlines that they would write on CNN
the New York Times Washington post about
Trump and linking him to Russia you
could basically cross out Trump and
replace it often with Democrats
sometimes establishment Republicans
Russia and put in China because the
connections exist so this whole idea
that there's this you know collaborating
conclusion with foreign governments and
like Democrats you guys wrote that
Playbook when you started taking cash
from Chinese Communist party influence
groups exactly and so we see how much
the goal post has moved over the years
right back in 2016 Donald Trump colluded
with the Russians we know he colluded
with the Russians the entire thing is a
bars the president is owned by the
Kremlin and then okay well well maybe he
colluded with them and then okay so well
there's no evidence that he colluded
with them but the investigation was done
in good faith and now it's okay well the
investigation wasn't done in good faith
and there were a lot of biases in it and
the FBI clearly played favorites by
warning the Clinton pick campaign not
the Trump campaign and they launched the
investigation on bad information but but
it wasn't too it was not an intentional
coup it's like okay I'm sure you know
every single thing you have said along
the way since this investigation first
began since this Russia gate farce was
incepted has been completely wrong and
now you expect us to believe you when
you say this wasn't a coup I'm sorry
we've run out of good faith the lawyer
involved in the first impeachment
tweeted out when Trump right before his
inauguration we are going to impeach you
yep like they expressed their intent
before there was any criminal
accusations or any any potential
wrongdoing or anything they could accuse
him of they said we will do it no matter
what and meanwhile in the same exact
time frame the FBI the treasury
Department was getting suspicious
activity report after suspicious
activity report based off the business
dealings of Hunter Biden and all you
know doesn't Biden family members and
they were actively suppressing that
these are obviously politically exposed
personnels peps so they knew what Hunter
Biden was doing from the financial
transactions and it just shows you it's
not even a double standard of Justice
because that implies that we're in the
same realm of Standards it's it's
otherworldly it's it's just ridiculous
yep and I think that there's a lot to
what you're saying Hannah Claire about
the fact that our institutions probably
will not punish themselves for their
wrongdoings I also hear what you're
saying Tim about the fact that Trump
being re-elected could mean that he
actually would go after these people and
they would be duly punished for their
crimes against this nation
but I will say one thing
I believe that the real black pill is
that is not that you know people who
have
information that could lead to the
arrest of Hillary Clinton die it's that
no amount of information will ever lead
to the arrest of Hillary Clinton right
uh and that applies overall to this deep
state that maybe Trump does get in maybe
he is able to appoint investigators it's
certainly going to be an uphill battle
man we should have titled today's
episode
Tim cast reveals information that will
lead to the arrest it's like see what
happens you know uh maybe it will maybe
it will yeah maybe when uh Trump gets
back in office he will finally follow
through with locking up Hillary Clinton
because uh
I mean this was it it was the Democrats
it was the clintons it was Obama they
were trying to intentionally smear
Donald Trump to win an election and they
framed him as a traitor to this country
yeah and the headlines are going to be
Donald Trump uses justice system for his
own vindictive means to an end you know
what I mean I mean even if we were to
get some of these official Behind Bars
to have to uh
publicly face what they have done to the
American people not just Donald Trump
but to the people who supported him
right
there is no way that the media lets this
go right even now I mean I think part of
this time exactly what you're saying the
timeline you lied out of being like
there definitely was a problem all the
way to like well there wasn't anything
and also we are biased and we're sort of
admitting it by now they're gonna be
like well but he just got found guilty
in this case and he's being investigated
over here and let's talk to Alvin Bragg
and it almost doesn't matter because
they were just waiting to come up with
something else to try and hold against
Trump and it is honestly astounding I
don't know that we'll ever see anything
like it in our lifetime of someone they
hate more than Donald Trump I mean it's
truly unbelievable like that mainstream
media and the Deep state will go to
fight against him well I will say I
think there is someone or more
accurately a group they hate more than
Donald Trump and that's the American
people and they see Donald Trump as a
representative for the actual interests
of the American people and that bothers
them because they're used to seeing
politicians who are only interested in
representing the elite and so while it
may be the case that none of these
people face any actual punishment at any
of these media establishments or
anywhere in the Deep state with respect
to public opinion and people waking up
to their nonsense the one thing I can
say is the walls are closing in I'm just
imagining like high profile Democrat
fundraisers holding auditions to recruit
actors to play Democrats and they're
doing the interview and they're like all
right give me populist and they got like
AOC and she's saying like I think we
should text the rich like this is really
great you're really good now if you take
this job we have to warn you you will
have to shake hands and touch these
people and then she shutters oh I think
I can do it all right you got the job
we'll uh we'll we'll get you elected and
then you can be a Democrat and that's
that's how I view that's how I view all
the Democrats and the Republicans and be
completely honest except for like five
people
they're just they just despise and are
disgusted by Americans yes no well
that's exactly what it is right it's
it's funny so there's this idea of
loving the The Sinner and hating the sin
you know the Democrats they they like
love poverty and hate the poor they
really do they have this entire idea in
their heads that they're these champions
for the working class and they hate
everything that the working class stands
for and they'll even claim that it's
funny it applies other things like they
really they like love immigration and
they hate the Immigrant when you talk to
people who come here from Mexico about
their values and like how they feel
about gay marriage and abortion the left
is disgusted by it they hate everything
they stand for yeah I mean all of the
counties along the border in Texas where
there are levels of immigration
are red right they are populated by
people whose families have migrated from
Mexico they have conservative values but
you you see that theory play out too I
think even with the Russia hoax because
I also never sort of bought what they
were pushing right it's like oh because
a random Facebook account that was
somewhat linked to Russia shared an
article that was attacking Hillary
Clinton on false terms just because some
random Americans read it that now
influenced their vote they're now voting
for Donald Trump and I think you know if
you unpack that whole narrative that
they were pushing it really shows you
how dumb they think the American people
are right and how really influenceable
and just
because you read an article now you your
entire conviction the reason why you
support trump it can't be because you
actually support his policies on trade
and you want to take this country back
and you despise Hillary Hillary Clinton
to your core it's because you read an
article about Hillary Clinton actually
being you know related to who knows it's
it's actually absolutely
ludicrous conspiracy theorizing what
they argued was that
non-government Russian actors spending
46 000 worth of money on Facebook ads
that weren't even all targeted towards
one specific party
was an act of War we had actual elected
leaders saying that that was an act of
war from Russia interfering in our
election this is how delusional these
people are the best part too is if you
look I remember there was a press
release that Twitter had put out
probably like two years ago they were
talking about what they were doing to
mitigate foreign influence and they had
ranked all the different numbers of bots
that they had from different countries
and overwhelmingly I think it was by
like a 10 increase or rather uh like
Chasm between Bots from China and Russia
the Chinese Communist party influence on
Twitter dwarfed that of Russia so it's
so funny if you want to play with this
foreign influence narrative it's like
sure I'll take you your word on that
even though I don't believe you the
American people are smart enough to be
immune to that uh even if you want to
take them at their word the Chinese
Communist Party their influence still
prevails over Russia so it's just
bizarre Tick Tock yeah taking over right
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time